[Applauso]
[Musica]
il nostro viaggio oggi inizia
nell'infinitamente piccolo in un mondo
microscopico e brulicante di vita che ci
circonda è stata in grado di colonizzare
ogni ambiente su questa terra compreso
il nostro corpo
il mondo dei batteri secondo voi vale la
pena interessarsi di esseri così
semplici che vengono generalmente
ricordati solo perché causa di qualche
malattia più o meno terribile
ovviamente per me c'è solo una risposta
a questa domanda certamente sì anche
perché sennò non sarei oggi qui con voi
anzi vi dirò di più sono molto
interessanti dimentichiamoci per un
momento del ruolo che hanno nei più
diversi ecosistemi di fatto i
microrganismi hanno plasmato il pianeta
su cui menia viviamo ad esempio quelli
che vedete qui indicati da una freccia
non sono scogli ma sono antiche colonie
batteriche fossili quello di cui oggi
vorrei parlarvi e di come i batteri ci
possono aiutare esattamente questi gli
animaletti come li chiama la mia nonna
che puzzano pure un po e richiamano
generalmente immagini poco carine di
sporcizia sono forse tra i nostri più
grandi alleati ad esempio al giorno
d'oggi vengono utilizzati in svariati
processi industriali come ad esempio la
produzione dello yogurt dell'aceto o per
pulire le acque fognarie possono essere
più utilizzati come fabbriche in
miniatura entrano le materie prime sotto
forma di cibo esce il prodotto
desiderato
in questo modo possiamo ottenere grandi
quantità di molecole biologiche che
altrimenti sarebbero difficilissimo da
recuperare ad esempio i nostri panni
vengano così ben puliti grazie ad anzi
mi che estraiamo dai batteri ma quello
di cui vorrei parlarvi oggi è ciò di cui
mi occupo io quindi la biologia
molecolare ed in questo campo
i batteri sono forse ancora più
importanti dovete sapere infatti che
negli anni settanta del secolo scorso e
l'ingresso dei batteri nei laboratori di
ricerca ha dato il via a quella che è
nota come rivoluzione del dna
ricombinante cioè abbiamo la capacità di
creare molecole dna divide linea su
misura
agendo un po come dei sarti che tagliano
e cucciano questo ha creato la moderna
biologia molecolare
io oggi riesco a fare il laboratorio
buona parte
nei miei esperimenti perché qualcuno 50
anni fa ha pensato che effettivamente i
batteri forse non erano poi così male ma
l'aspetto più paradossale del nostro
rapporto con questi microscopici esseri
a proprio a che vedere con la nostra
salute
perché se è vero che ci fanno ammalare
anche in maniera molto grave
e tuttavia anche vero che ci aiutano a
restare sani ed è questo paradosso che
io oggi vorrei esplorare con voi
partiamo però con un quiz così vediamo
quanto siete preparati quali di questi
tre farmaci arrivano oggi nelle nostre
farmacie e nei nostri ospedali grazie
batteri la vancomicina che uno degli
antibiotici più potenti che abbiamo
attualmente a disposizione
l'insulina che è necessaria ogni giorno
milioni di pazienti diabetici o l'ormone
della crescita a mani alzate b e c vedo
poco convinti comunque la verità è che
tutti e tre questi farmaci oggi vengono
prodotti grazie batteri io penso che
solo questo andrebbe avervi convinto ma
la storia che mi sta a cuore oggi è
diversa ed è esemplare per molti versi è
una storia che a che vedere con la
curiosità tipica dei ricercatori in
realtà di noi tutti forse nell'osservare
la realtà che ci circonda è una storia
che comincia 30 anni fa con lo studio
del genoma di alcuni batteri e si
conclude solo oggi con una scoperta che
al potenziale di rivoluzionare la
medicina e non solo leggendo quindi il
dna contenuto in queste cellule
batteriche il loro genoma appunto
costituito da una sequenza di qualche
milione delle quattro basi a tgc ci si
era accorti che alcune sequenze quindi
delle stringhe di lettere venivano
ripetute nel loro genoma più e più volte
in modo molto misterioso vedete noi
ricercatori
siamo fatti così incontriamo qualcosa di
insolito e non ci sia più dalla testa e
ci pensiamo ancora e ancora
finché non troviamo una soluzione per un
fenomeno che apparentemente non ha una
spiegazione e nonostante magari i nostri
stessi colleghi ci dicano guarda che
stai perdendo tempo
in questo caso però questa cocciutaggine
stata proprio una grande fortuna
l'altra cosa che ci piace a noi dialoghi
molecolari sono gli acronimi quindi
queste corte sequenze ripetute
palindrome raggruppate e regolarmente
spaziate che in inglese suona come
france cluster dell'agro inter space
short palindromi three peat diventano
per il bene di tutti chris per facciamo
ora un salto in avanti nel tempo di una
ventina d'anni circa e con gli anni
accumuliamo le conoscenze che abbiamo
raccolto grazie al lavoro di decine e
decine di persone che ricordate non
stavano cercando la cura per tutti i
mali ma si stanno semplicemente
meravigliando davanti al funzionamento
di una cellula semplice come quella
batterica e arriviamo al primo traguardo
della nostra storia di oggi cioè capire
a cosa servono veramente le sequenze
christer siete d'accordo con me che su
questo pianeta al di là dei batteri
esistono poche forme di vita più
semplici bene penso di sì per quanto
semplici in quanto forme di vita anche i
batteri possono ammalarsi
avete capito bene esistono infatti
queste cose che vedete dietro di me che
sembrano tanto sonde spaziali in
atterraggio se qualche pinta sconosciuto
ma in realtà sono virus batteriofagi un
nome molto evocativo mangiatori di
batteri ed in effetti sono virus dei
batteri in quanto virus sono parenti dei
nostri virus come influenza e infettano
ed uccidono i loro ospiti
l'avreste mai detto ma la parte migliore
secondo me deve ancora arrivare
un organismo semplice unicellulare
microscopico come un batterio si difende
come con qualcosa che somiglia toe
sistema immunitario non solo questo
sistema immunitario a memoria delle
infezioni passate e può combattere
efficacemente se si ripresentano nel
futuro i batteri hanno un sistema
immunitario non lo trovate meraviglioso
secondo me è la natura è veramente
fantastica
immagino tra l'altro che vi immaginate a
a questo punto dove voglio arrivare
chris par è questo sistema immunitario
vediamo come funziona
i batteriofagi hanno anche loro un
genoma che introducono all'interno del
batterio infettato questo è una sorta di
manuale di istruzioni che obbliga il
batterio e produrre migliaia e migliaia
di nuove particelle virali
pronte per la diffusione ricordiamoci
però che il batterio nel suo genoma le
sequenze chris per che possono essere
paragonate a un grande archivio di foto
segnaletiche che vengono utilizzate da
una sorta di polizia cellulare che li
gli addetti ai lavori hanno identificato
con la proteina kras nine per
identificare e distruggere virus
invasori come la proteina casna in è una
forbice molecolare che taglia il dna una
nucleari questo è il termine tecnico che
taglia e fa a pezzi il genoma del virus
invadente quindi niente più genoma
niente più istruzioni su come proseguire
in infezione queste forbici poi non sono
banali poiché non tagliano a caso ma
possono essere programmate contro i
virus utilizzando le nostre foto
segnaletiche che nella realtà
corrispondono a corte molecole di rna
che è uno stretto parente del dna
ottenute proprio a partire dalle nostre
sequenze crispano
a questo punto immagino che ha visto
lati starete chiedendo cosa c'entra
tutto questo io vi avevo promesso di
parlare di avanzamento nel campo della
medicina
beh torniamo nel 2012
a questo punto entra in scena uno dei
migliori esempi di pensiero laterale
dell'ultimo degli ultimi tempi
all'angolo diametralmente opposto delle
scienze biologiche e quello della
ricerca applicata alla terapia genica e
l'ingegneria genetica da tempo ci si
spremeva le meningi per trovare un modo
semplice ed efficace per introdurre
modificazioni a livello di specifiche
sequenze all'interno di un genoma
dopo anni di studi si era capito che
tagliando il dna di una cellula questa
cellula quindi anche una delle nostre
cellule tenderà a riparare il danno e
nelle giuste condizioni è possibile
manipolare questo processo per
riscrivere alcune delle lettere che
compongono il suo patrimonio genetico
quindi quello che serviva era una
forbice molecolare facilmente
programmabile in modo da poter inserire
dei tagli a livello delle sequenze che
vogliamo modificare questo vi ricorda
per caso qualcosa da snai ovviamente
l'idea di far incontrare la ricerca di
base e quindi lo studio dei batteri con
la ricerca applicata quindi la terapia
genica e stato l'elemento vincente e da
creato una svolta inaspettata per la
prima volta siamo capaci di modificare
in maniera semplice economica ed
efficace il genoma dei più diversi
organismi e quando dico semplice
economica ed efficace no sto scherzando
ha fatto nel senso che adesso noi
potremmo sederci ad un tavolo e insieme
e pianificare un esperimento di modifica
del genoma di alcune cellule in coltura
come quelle che ho io nel mio
laboratorio
dopodiché io potrei con qualche decina
di euro recuperare i materiali necessari
ovviamente una parte dirigenti sono già
disponibili in laboratorio tornare
all'università e mettermi al lavoro ci
potremo poi rivedere fra una settimana
e al 90 per cento vi potrei portare una
coltura di cellule con la modificazione
che avevamo deciso di inserire almeno
per alcuni tipi di modificazione prima
mi ci sarebbero voluti dei mesi e ben
più di pochi euro
quindi è chiaro che questo tipo di
esperimenti era erano fattibili solo da
pochi laboratori al mondo
chris par invece adesso è veramente per
tutti so che questa sembra una
televendita ma non è così
le sensazione veramente questa ed in
effetti chris per sé è diffuso a macchia
d'olio nei laboratori di ricerca e non
solo qui ad esempio vedete un grafico
che rappresenta il numero di
pubblicazioni scientifiche riguardanti
chris par nel corso degli anni una bella
crescita non trovate
ma veniamo al punto 5.291 questo è il
numero noto di malattie genetiche
causate dalla mutazione quindi da un
errore in uno dei nostri geni
e questa è la stima che fanno i
ricercatori è anche più elevata o se
volete 3.645 che è il numero di geni
mutati che causano una di queste
malattie
tenete presente che il nostro genoma
contiene circa 20 mila geni quindi fate
un poco i conti queste sono le
cosiddette malattie rare
certo è che sono un gruppo bello folto
per cui nella pratica si è calcolato che
circa un bambino nato ogni 100 sia
affetto da una di questa malattia
mica poi tanto rare alla fine ed in più
hanno generalmente effetti devastanti
l'altro brutto nome che ricevono è
quello di malattie orfane nessuno se ne
occupa perché
ho troppo complesse o troppo rare per
per essere studiate crispa per la prima
volta nella storia della medicina ci
permette di immaginare una cura per
queste malattie
certo ci vorrà del tempo ma ci stiamo
già lavorando e non siamo più costretti
a dichiararsi sconfitti in partenza
ad esempio mente stiamo parlando è in
fase di partenza una sperimentazione
clinica in pazienti che fa uso di chris
parkas line per curare la beta
talassemia o anemia mediterranea soli
sei anni per passare dal laboratorio di
ricerca alla sperimentazione i pazienti
sono un bel record per queen's park e
dimostrano di nuovo il potenziale
rivoluzionaria di questa tecnologia
quindi a questo punto sembrerebbe un po
la cura per tutti i mali ma in realtà
purtroppo anche chris para i suoi
difetti
stiamo parlando di una forbice
molecolare che riconosce il suo
bersaglio ma cosa succede se lo manca ci
troveremmo nella situazione paradossale
che per correggere un errore all'interno
del genova di un paziente e introdurremo
di nuovi con effetti non sempre
facilmente prevedibili anche perché la
modifica del genoma è qualcosa di
permanente quindi una volta fatta rimane
lì e ci accompagna per tutto il resto
della vita
questo chiaramente è una cosa ottima se
stiamo parlando della correzione di un
errore
mica tanto se è chiaramente una modifica
è stata introdotta per sbaglio la
precisione quindi in questo campo è
importante
purtroppo però le forbici crispa si sono
evolute per funzionare all'interno di
una cellula batterica che ha un genoma
che è molto più semplice di quello di
una cellula umana
ed è proprio da questo che veniva loro
scarsa l'angolo scarsa precisione in
natura non hanno bisogno di essere super
precise
semplicemente perché hanno meno
possibilità di fare degli errori
fortuna tuttavia queste forbici
preferiscono comunque tagliare il loro
bersaglio e solo dopo si dirigono verso
altre zone a cui non dovrebbero
interessarsi il gruppo di ricerca in cui
lavoro ha sviluppato un metodo che
permette a queste forbici di auto
distruggersi dopo che hanno svolto il
loro compito evitando quindi
l'introduzione di spiacevoli errori
all'interno della cellula bersaglio
abbiamo creato un bisturi genomico usa e
getta che se applicate in campo medico
pensiamo possa aiutare a limitare o
ridurre gli effetti collaterali che
potrebbero aversi nei pazienti in
aggiunta la proteina acas nine è una
forbice di origine batterica quindi noi
non vogliamo che stia troppo a lungo del
nostro corpo come ogni farmaco deve fare
il suo lavoro e poi andarsene
il nostro sistema di autodistruzione fa
esattamente questo come spero di aver
fatto capire i batteri ci hanno regalato
uno strumento fantastico uno strumento
che promette di rivoluzionare la
genetica la medicina l'agricoltura la
nostra vita insomma i batteri a questo
punto il loro lavoro l'hanno fatto
ora sta a noi a tutti noi decidere come
far uso di questo strumento
c'è chi come me ne apprezza le
potenzialità in campo medico e vede
chris par come la chiave per accedere a
cure prima inimmaginabili
certo non sarà facile ma penso che
dobbiamo provarci
c'è chi invece ne vede i lati più oscuri
ovvero il cosiddetto effetto della china
scivolosa
si parte curando le malattie genetiche e
si finisce come ordinare i figli da un
catalogo decidendo a priori ha né
caratteristica fisica e genetica
chiaramente non siamo ancora arrivati a
questo punto ma tutto va visto in
prospettiva per scongiurare questo
rischio ad esempio sarebbe possibile
limitare l'uso delle forbici chris para
solo ad alcune specifiche situazioni
come ad esempio la cura di malattie
genetiche non in individui già nati da
questo punto di vista la comunità
scientifica è generalmente d'accordo che
prima di tentare applicazioni
particolarmente avanzate è bene
conoscere nel dettaglio il modo in cui
chris per funziona all'interno del corpo
umano
in definitiva comunque sarà la società
civile a determinare quali saranno
leciti per questo strumento
davanti a tutto ciò essere sospettosi
intimoriti o anche impauriti è
comprensibile
io tuttavia penso che queste sensazioni
non debbano indurci a smetta di fare
ricerca sempre con etica e trasparenza
perché solo in questo modo saremo in
grado di mettersi piatti della bilancia
il bene e il male di chris pari in modo
onesto e razionale e decidere verso che
direzione vogliamo muovere i nostri
passi tutti insieme come come esseri
umani grazie
[Applauso]